こんにちははじめ社長です
年かあんまり方が苦しい感じでは行きたくないんでちょっと自然な感じでいきたいと
思います数えてるんですね面白くしたいわけじゃないんですけどもという気では
シンプルに言いますと動画のタイトルにもありますように肇社長は-1
個人としてもですし畑として後のインフルエンサーとして
ヒカキンさんの今やられているヤフーさんの取り組みですね命を守る
人を支えたこれだ医療支援募金に1000万円寄付させていただきましたというご報告
です
すごいもうすぐによく集まるんですねはいこの日か議員さんとヤフーさんという
立ち上げたネット募金なんですけども集めた武器の使い道として東京都などの実際を
通して医療現場にマスクや消毒液防護服などの医療用品を配布
営業従事者のニーズに応じた活動
ここの npo への支援感染防止活動を行う npo 非営利団体ですねえぇを目的
としてない団体への支援
こちらが寄付金の使い道になっております額は悩みましたね企画23日を下したんでは
すごいって本当に普通に思って当初がこんなからで勢いで1億円募金しようかなと思っ
たんですけどもやっぱりガクガクなんでいろいろ
人と話し合ったわけですよどうしようかと前年6はここで一応を出してもいいって結構
思ってたんですけどねちょっと色んな事を考えますったねそれ本当に何か早めに僕は
ちょっと広めたかったんでなんか送金と加入金とかも結構時間かかってた分朝って
くらいにもう入金できると思うんですけど
出来る限りのキングだした一滴もつあったんですけど僕と
がまだせても1億ぐらいかなっていう話になっててまた本準備期間がいる踏まえるとも
トータルでまぁ1000万円ぐらいが一番コースっと
早めにこう入金相銀できて募金できる金額だったんで高が1千万円をさせていただき
ました
なんかいろいろ考えたんですよね今回のこの募金をするって活動を通してなんか色んな
おっ
大江いただきます本当にありがとうございますチャリティ活動に参加しませんかとか
こういうふうに募金どうですかとか一緒に何か一緒に何か頑張ろうっていう結構言われ
たりするんですけども
年間難しかったです具体的にそれなんだろって思うような活動だでもありましたし
内容ってが一体型わかってるけど具体的にどう使われるっていうのがちょっとよく
わかん
に募金とかもたまにあるじゃないですかそんな中ですよやっぱり僕は信頼なるヒカキン
さんがあゆすごくわかりやすく6加速信頼できでしょうばかり安になって思ったんで
今回募金させていただきました
恋愛あのー
難しいすね何が難しいかというとその募金先なんですよ
医療機関への募金はもちろん大事だと思っております
なんならまずそれが一番最初ですただ現状だけ見ますとそのこれノイズの感染者が
かなり
日本減ってきてるんですか東京とかもうちょっと人気たでしょ僕が賛成し増加も相当
長い期間02なんでリアーですよ
現場はですこれからどうなるか分からないですべてかもしれないんですけども
現場は割とちょっとずつ感染者数が減ってきたのかなっていう収束に向かっているよう
な気がします気がしませなだけなんであの本当にわからないですけどねこの後この日本
とか経済がどうなっていくかってをもっと
それがまたわからないデブイージーさあおりました
伝え大地など寿司
はあの
どうなるかわかりませんこのなぁいいですとかこの蔓延した後もこの先ちょっとあの
どうなるか分かりません本当にも花が咲き気になったのがなんかニュースとかで見てて
なんか大学生がめちゃくちゃ今学校を辞めてるらしいんですよ
なぜかと言いますとバイト先がクビになったりバイト先が想像も潰れたり
自粛とかでもお金を払う手段が無いとかでわからないんですけど他の親阻止奥いう形し
てる
応援もお仕事がなくなったり自粛に仕事ができなかったり2この先がつぶれたりして
本当にお金学費も払えない状況になってしまって大学を辞めざるを得ないという学生
さんが結構いるとか
まあ今も行ったんですけどその通りも本当に根本的に仕事がなくなってしまった飲食店
とかサービス今日もう全然あのー生前頭が回らない今言ったの正面上だけな問題かも
しれない
夫が僕たちが知らないところでいろんな人が来る住んで非常に苦しい生活を迫られて
いることもあると思うんですけどもそれが今あまりに多すぎるし今後それがどう変わっ
ていくかもわからないしなんならコロナの闇ってこのほど揺れ様が別にある気がしてて
やっぱりみんなの命を守るために自粛とか絶対必要だったんですけども自粛したことに
よる経済的
被害それが本当に実は計り知れないんじゃないかなと思っています
だからまつげなく医療機関とか病院とかそういうのは本当に一番必要根本にあるんです
けども俺は
この後もっとくるのかなと思ってます経済的被害とかねそれじゃあ俺もちょっと考え
まとまってなくていろいろベラベラしゃべってるんですけども難しいんだよねほんとに
はカーンにするどこにどういう影響が出ているか今度ねねころないレッサーまだまだ
始まったばっかりだと思ってます表面上のそのウィルスっていうのはもう収束に近づい
てますけどいるんじゃなくて経済停止自粛によって人がし
死んでいく気がする現状だとまつげなる必要なことなので1000万円別にもっと出せ
ますよアピールとかしたいんじゃなくて現場僕が1000万円だけ募金されていただき
ました
1000万円に狭いってますけどだからね伊勢マイカーからねあの本当に自信とか災害
とはちょっと分けが違って上によってどこが止まってどういう影響を及ぼしたのか
か車がちょっと複雑すぎで絵本
何パッド今何かをして全部解決することができないと思ってるんですが現像
この社会この日本なので本当はあの当初する予定だった
じゃあこの先をそれがわかんないすそんな中言ったら絶対典型みたいな空気なるんで
絶対ショートが言ってないんですけどやる意思はありますトータルでもうちょっと冒険
賞と思ってた部分を私はじめ冊はまた僕の前の人たちと話し合ってちょっと今後の動き
にはは
てていろいろ支援していければいいなと思っておりますというご報告ですので完全に
個人の思いの話を知っていますはいと言うであの日か議員の募金相当集まっております
もうすぐ多分2億円達成されると思うので動画の概要欄に募金するサイトを貼っておき
ますこちらから是非皆さん
昨日よろしくお願い致しますん以上期間はマジ大事だと思うまずはそこなんでそこ地本
なんて生活のただその先あの僕とかさあの酒井人とかさあ大人の人の自粛期間は
まあまあ百歩譲って言うなら僕は別にいいと思ってて
人生的な3でね全然良いと思ってて子どもたちとか学生さんの
を自粛期間
本当にちょっと悲しいもんだと思いますね
学生時代の時間で本当にかけがえのないものなんでその大事な時間をねほんとに色々
中止にしたらいい学校行けなかったりいろいろ見て学んで経験できる大事な機会は相当
のがせる気がしてるんだよ個人的な思いとしてはそういうこの先の社会になっていく
ような未来ある学生とか何か手出す
出てきたらなっていう気持ちはちょっと強いですすいませんあの
ほんとわかんないですよそういうさあ金が無くて困ってる大学生を助けるところが動画
僕するとわかんないんで真っていうか本当にわからどこで何すればいいですか
ございませんただヒカキンさんの募金を本当にわかりやすかったのでとりあえずまずは
募金させていただきましたという感じですはいもうちょっと
はいもう自転車と揺れてもか
ありませんとりあえずなんか金額も取れず言おうと思ってその人とかこの先僕がどう
いう活動していろんな人に支援していきたいかとかそういう意思があるのかどうだとか
ちょっとまとめて話させていただきました本当に戦いますでここからだと思うので可能
な鍵でみんなで力を合わせながらもう日本みんなの一部とかじゃなくて全員のもとあっ
た実情を取り戻せればいいなと思っております
美さんにまともにしゃべれました明日からふざけますじゃ
あっハール blr